so my name is Kevin Preble I am a
research focus data scientist at Humana
and today I'm going to be giving a brief
introduction to patchy Zeppelin
notebooks using high spark 2.0 I had
posted in the slack Chad the repo for
this talk and you can grab it from here
if you'd like to build it yourself
I wouldn't recommend trying it now it
takes about two hours you to build spark
and everything else from from scratch
but it has a vagrant and VirtualBox
solution and in Hanceville recipe and it
should build everything for you you can
go ahead and start that up yourself if
you'd like to try that out later
so the question I get a lot is what R is
up on notebooks we have Jupiter
notebooks that everyone is pretty
familiar with our studio is started
there are no books and those are kind of
the big ones and in zeppelin notebooks
are practice are looking to be the
all-in-one notebook so dashboard
websocket you can use that to share data
they have interpreters for both big and
small data solutions and it's it's
pretty flexible but it's a little
rougher than the moment so some
background on zeppelin it just graduated
to be a top-level project for apache'
back in May and it had been with Apache
since December of 2014
originally it was based on a commercial
product that didn't go very far just
something I had the support and so it
was donated to Apache where it has
gotten a lot of attention pretty quickly
and again it's supposed to be a
multi-purpose notebook to handle
ingestion discovery analytics and then
visualization and collaboration so right
now there are about 20 different
backends that except one supports a lot
of the popular ones you have our Python
PI spark all the the Apache databases
are there one of the nice things about
zeppelin notebooks is that you're able
to write your own interpreter and so if
you have a data source that isn't
currently supported it's pretty easy to
write your own in java or its child so
one of the big differences between the
zeppelin notebooks and jupiter notebooks
is that jupiter notebooks started as an
offshoot of the ipython notebook so
there's python-based relatively focused
on that environment whereas up when
notebooks are
pretty tightly integrated with spark in
Hadoop so it's much more focused on
large data Big Data solutions and that
integration is pretty evident as you go
through so it's written in Java
and so you can stay in the same language
as you go through it's got automatic
injection for sequel for spark you can
use your Java runtime libraries and the
dependencies directly from Zeppelin and
then you can cancel and display jobs
that are currently running in spark
directly from cellphone notebooks data
visualization is also a key element of
Zeppelin or books so it has some basic
charts built in interactive charts one
thing that we don't see in Jupiter
notebooks and for anything that's not
currently supported by the built-in
visualizations you can display any other
visualization library that you like such
as not qualitative C warned or if you're
using our ggplot2
so Zeppelin sits between the SPARC
interpreter and then the web output that
you see so there's a Zeppelin server
that runs in the backend of a web socket
with REST API that presents the data to
your web browser and then you can view
the data either as text HTML is
interviewed in tabular data or it just
recently upgraded to angular 2.0 it was
angular 1.6 before that this is a quick
snapshot of what the built-in chart
types look like for step one so if you
have a data structure you can pull it
into these built-in chart types so it
has built-in pivot charts very similar
to what you would expect to see with
Excel a7 how you're able to do this you
know
book format i evolved on spark and
hadoop so you're able to scale that data
processing much more than you could with
other tools and so this is just a
picture of what that would look like so
you can in the values for the balance
and average you can do max min sum the
min and a few others and then depending
on what groupings you have in keys you
can build your tables very similar
abilities very similarly to how you do
them in Excel sup 1 Oaks also have very
flexible layouts something that is
currently missing from Jupiter so you're
able to set the width of your these are
called paragraphs in Zeppelin instead of
cells and so you can set the cell width
or the paragraph width and you can move
them up and down and arrange them I will
Zeppelin also has built in dynamic forms
so if you need to provide some input
this is just a quick picture of what
they look like I'll show a demonstration
of these in a minute and it's also
really focused on collaborative sharing
so it has built in its removing for
version control something that has been
very difficult to do in Joop your
notebooks with its JSON format so you
can one click version control in Jupiter
or in a Zeppelin you can also use the
built-in WebSocket to output any of your
graphs directly to your web browser and
share those and host those in an iframe
inside of your website so there's just a
quick picture of what that would look
like and so since this is PI data
I built my Zeppelin instance using
passport or spark 2.0 and so I just want
to briefly touch on what
some of the new features of spark 2.0
are spark - who I know is kind of a
unifying release it brings the data
frame and data set differences between
Java and Python into kind of unity and
so due to the lack of type safety for
armed Python data frame is the main
programming interface
it also has substantially improved SQL
support so you can do sub queries
finally which is very nice before you
were able to do that you also have
native CSV you reading
thanks to data bricks and then it is
substantially faster than previous
versions of spark so between 2 and 10
times faster for common sequel operators
and then data frame operations and then
for the machine learning library ml lip
you have model persistence and so it
you're also able to pipeline your data
much better than you were in previous
releases and the pipeline's are pretty
similar across the different languages
college of Python and R and then there
are many more machine learning models
that you're able to do including Lenard
screen analysis gaussian mixture
modeling general linear regression and
more than these were all missing
previously from the earlier releases so
that's a much as I have 4 slides but I'm
gonna pop into a new Zeppelin instance
I'm gonna show you what we're working
with so I have this running off the
local virtual machine from the github
repo and so I'll go ahead and just
quickly make sure that spark is running
and so my kanpai spark you can see that
everything's get there you can pour your
most popular libraries numpy scifi
pandas and anything else that you may
want jhoom in yep
is that better okay a little bit of
delay and so as we mentioned there's the
built-in visualization libraries but
you're also able to use any of the other
visualization libraries which mia like
so for example I'll go ahead and I will
plot with that pot Lib and we get the
output in a line just like you would
with Jupiter and if you want to do
something a bit fancier you can go ahead
and get a much prettier visualization
you can also use your standard pandas
libraries if you want to import data
directly from a CSV source and this is
something new for support 2.0 so I'll
grab the Titanic data set
I knew recorded via pandas and one of
the other nice things that you can do
with Zeppelin is that you're able to
pass data or objects directly between
languages within the notebook and so
right now I'll create an object in SPARC
this Python secret and then I can pass
it directly back to PI SPARC and Python
and then actually where is
sure
so let me zoom out just a little bit
I had these out of order so what I need
to do here
so you can go ahead and move the cell up
I should have run this one first and I
can get that object back from spark so
you pass back and forth that way again
you can use it smoother visualization
libraries I'll just draw science wave
and so I'm very familiar but you have
the ability to plot in Y as well so you
grab a couple other interesting things
about step one so here are some of the
dynamic forms and so using markdown in a
Cell you can type in name and get that
out in your output you can also have
drop-down forms directly in there so
Dave Monday it's Thursday and that is
just using markdown but if you want to
use spark a spark you can do the same
thing and here this is just a mapping of
values so the different days to members
so if you have a dashboard that you're
trying to create you can create these
dropdowns and dynamic forms very easily
so this is just another example of the
built-in plotting library so go ahead
and grab this text
so I have to zoom out just a little bit
to get this all on the screen there's
just a word count for a block of text
but you can view this table for each of
the words and use a bar chart you can
change the sum to count total counts
then can you give me some pie charts
although this particular one doesn't
work well as a pie chart or an area plot
you can also do built-in maps and then I
had a bit more presented setup but I was
built in point six and six point six one
it's not working so I'm going to grab
this off as a sub one hug and this is
another example of some of the dynamic
charts that you can do within cell phone
so here we're grabbing Bank data by age
to view it as group or stacked so again
you can change the values directly
within your your charts going to view it
as a pie chart you can do that as well
again and this is all just running off
of support so you can use any of the
interpreters dynamically within within
the different paragraphs and so if we
want to
I can't do it on this one but go ahead
and show you how you can output directly
to a web socket so it's a head and
it's
wink this out and then you can put this
in an iframe directly within your
website and I mentioned built-in version
control
so you can go ahead and commit so one
and just that easily are there any
questions yes
on the hub that's just you can use W get
or anything else you want to in order to
import that data directly to your VM or
your spark instance so this would just
be bouncing off the spark instance there
is I'm grabbing this off it's up on
hover the moment is that the
visualizations aren't working with 0.61
yes
yeah so you can you can hide the output
you can
and hide it insured the editor you can
hide the output and then you can also
switch the entire notebook to be a
report to where none of the actual input
is shown and so nobody can go ahead and
change that when you're sharing it and
then you can also do a simpler layout
that takes away some of the version
control buttons and some of other things
so if you want to make sure that people
can access data natively but they don't
have the option to edit or change
something other features of the notebook
you can go ahead and switch the layout